I it looks like it's sort of going away
on its own right now I seen you have
raised to the top you know taking the
salience in how states and districts are
orienting their work it still matters
tremendously in in terms of how schools
in the public sort of see local
accountability I started teaching at a
time when the special education and the
in our classrooms were all in the
basement and those were the classrooms
that got the books last because they
didn't count in the test course so
there's this an element of No Child Left
Behind that I have always applauded
which is that it it it expanded the
demand for hard work and progress to
every single child I think it did it
very bluntly and with with huge
consequences in terms of narrowing of
instruction it was also in many ways to
too timid in that it never defined
standards it it left untouched questions
of equity as in you know it called for
highly qualified teachers but it did
nothing about making sure that they
ended up in the poorest schools or a
call for choice but it made choice
within districts well what if the
district's don't have enough good
schools for choice it didn't open up the
choice to the adjacent suburb where you
know all the middle class kids are so
you know it was very bold in some ways
it was very very timid and others
clearly in many things about it now
change the accountability system will be
different the move towards common
standards is has
extraordinary velocity right now the
nature of the test is going to change so
you know I'm intrigued by what happens
in the next couple of years because it
it potentially reorients everything and
one of the amazing things that are that
the new administration has done is its
settle very early on a on a change in
practice before the you know the big the
big leaver for the federal government
was was money as always and but the
money always went out you know in in a
formula what what has been happening is
that the money has huge amounts of money
are now discretionary they're being
distributed in a discretionary way and
that has created a stampede tours these
dollars and of course everybody trying
to qualify for the dollars in ways that
has completely shifted how you know
certain states are looking at the work
you know it's quite impressive I mean I
give I give the Secretary of Education
enormous credit for this you know it I
don't think I would have been able to
think of it so so I applaud him